no more heroes 3 is set to be released
soon and since i've never played a no
more heroes game before i thought now
would be the perfect time to pull it out
of my ever expanding backlog and try it
out and what better place to start than
the very first entry in the series
simply titled no more heroes it was
released for the nintendo wii in 2007 in
japan and 2008 everywhere else you'll
notice that this gameplay is in crispy
hd because i'm playing the switchboard
but the question remains is no more
heroes any good and does it hold up in
2021 well in this video i plan to answer
that question as i check out the
original no more heroes i know a lot of
gamers out there don't have much
patience at least that's what bishop the
dude at the video store said
[Music]
i don't care about titles or power i
just want to be number one
am i ready
anytime
[Music]
for those who don't know no more heroes
is about a 27 year old man named travis
touchdown who loves wrestling in anime
and lives at the no more heroes motel in
the fictional santa destroy california
and all he wants to do is become the
number one ranked assassin in the
country travis is very crude very blunt
and very
horny okay how about this if i become
number one will you do it with me the
game also never takes itself too
seriously for example if you want to
save your game you have to use the
toilet to do so
[Music]
if the sound of all that repulses you
then i'm sorry it's really not going to
get any better from here that's just how
no more heroes is we've got plenty of
other videos here on gamespot and if
there was ever a place to ask you to go
check them out this would be it no more
heroes is the brainchild of one goichi
suda aka sudo51 if you're interested in
learning more about sudo51 we did an
episode of our show audio logs with him
where he broke down his iconic career a
link to that video will be in the
description here's the beam katana and
and this was not inspired by star wars
that's what i've been telling people for
years for safety no more heroes was
originally planned for the xbox 360
under the working title project heroes
but after the executive producer
suggested the then unknown wii console
suda saw the appeal and saw how the wii
remote would work after some initial
hesitation if you ask me the wii motion
controls and sword play go hand in hand
so this was a smart move to help the
game stand out as an m rated wii
exclusive
[Music]
anyways enough about the backstory how's
the game itself and should you go back
and play it in the lead up to three well
first let's start with the good aspects
of no more heroes travis wins a beam
katana totally not a lightsaber from an
online auction and with that he's able
to slice his way through anyone that
stands between him and his goal what's
unique about the combat is that after
taking down an enemy's health bar you're
instructed to swing the remote in a
direction shown on screen and then bam
you just slice them clean and are
treated to a lot of animated blood and a
very harrowing scream
after you successfully land this death
blow as the game calls it you'll see a
little slot machine appear at the bottom
of the screen and if you're lucky and
you get three in a row then you'll get a
special ability like strawberry on the
shortcake that makes your beam katana
highly charged increases your movement
speed and lets you do a death blow in
any direction after hitting an enemy
once strawberry on the shark tank
and as mentioned earlier not only is
travis a big anime loving otaku but he
also loves wrestling and if the
opportunity presents itself then you can
lay the smackdown on your enemies by
following some simple on-screen prompts
after stunning them and while all this
is fun the game's combat system doesn't
truly evolve throughout the course of
the game you can and will unlock new
beam katanas as you go on and you can
buy some upgrades for them but it's just
the same slicing and dicing over and
over until you're the number one ranked
assassin you know what i think the
combat is like though it's like eating a
bag of potato chips you know that
feeling when you've been munching on
chips for a while and even though you
might be done with it your mouth is just
craving more munching that's the best
way i could sum up the combat of this
game so even though it doesn't exactly
change in any significant way the combat
is still a lot of fun and seriously
addictive it is really cool how they all
die also i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention that charging up the beam katana
requires you to shake the remote as if
you're jacking off
if that isn't the perfect self-aware use
of the wii remote or joy-con then i
don't know what is however if you're
playing the nintendo switch port you do
get the benefit of using button controls
instead of motion controls if you choose
i like the button controls a lot but the
impact of swinging the beam katana
certainly gets lost although i do like
how the right stick is used to mimic the
sword actions taking a page out of
skyward sword hd's book or did skyward
sword mimic no more heroes the other
great aspect of this game is the ranked
assassin fights which is a good thing
because if those weren't fun then the
entire game would crumble the ranked
assassin fights are like boss battles
but they play a larger part in the story
too travis starts the game at rank
number 11 and to become number one he
has to take down each ranked assassin
one by one and climb the list who
manages this list you might ask the
united assassins association aka the uaa
why does the uaa exist play the game and
find out what works so well though is
that each ranked assassin not only has a
unique style and personality but each
fight keeps you on your toes and has
something different to throw at you
check it out
but at the same time each assassin
doesn't get a whole lot of screen time
you don't even get to know a whole lot
about them but all their stories are
kind of tragic and they're either filled
with regret or jaded by the job their
ego is so massive it has blinded them
you're no assassin you're just a
perverted killing maniac in essence
they're the same don't go on thinking
you're better than me the game
definitely doesn't glorify these people
and instead it shows the harsh realities
of achieving your dream and the baggage
that comes with it even when travis
himself is so blinded by being number
one
man this is what i live for fighting
your own kind nothing's more gratifying
i won't spoil anything major because if
you're interested so far i do encourage
you to try the game for yourself but
ultimately the ranked assassin battles
are a lot of fun to play and add a lot
of interesting layers to the overall
story
now you might be thinking to yourself
okay well some addictive combat that
feels like junk food and a bunch of
unique and interesting enemies probably
a short and fun game right well let's
get into the more divisive parts of this
game that don't make it ages gracefully
after beating one of the ranked
assassins you'll need to pay an entry
fee to fight the next one and that entry
fee goes up every time usually about 50
000 more lb dollars as they're called in
game there are two main things you could
do to earn the cash first you can go to
the job center as a new job is posted
after each ranked assassin fight usually
these jobs consist of mundane tasks like
collecting coconuts or mowing grass
if you score a silver medal or better at
these jobs you'll be recommended for
two new assassination gigs at k
entertainment a corrupt ad agency that
employs people to
assassinate for money usually after
doing the side job and assassination
gigs you'll have enough money to get to
the next ranked assassin battle but
there's also naomi who can upgrade your
beam katana and the thunder ryu building
where you can train to become stronger
and increase your health
[Music]
those things also cost money so if you
decide to spend your money there then
you might need to redo a side job or
assassination gig to get the amount
needed for the next ranked battle and on
top of that to even get from place to
place you need to ride your motorcycle
around the town of santa destroy and
honestly the town is so barren that all
you'll really be doing is going from
place to place over and over again i
guess it makes sense in a city where
assassins reigned supreme and tons of
henchmen openings exist that the town
lost all of its residents to murder but
my point is this all feels very
repetitive and mundane and it starts to
feel like a chore after a while now
here's the thing about all this it's
boring there's no getting around that
but it also feels
intentional by design like think about
it if you want to become number one in
anything you got to work hard to be
number one sometimes you have to work
odd jobs like collecting garbage or
filling cars with gas to ultimately
achieve your
goals they also say practice makes
perfect and doing these extra
assassination gigs helps travis improve
his combat skills even if for the player
it's just a video game in an interview
with endgamer suda51 said and i quote we
want to include the message in our games
that some jobs aren't important and you
may hate them but if you do them to the
best of your ability it'll turn out well
better times will come but this begs the
question just because this feels
intentional to the style and message of
the game do you have to put up with it
in a video game a place where you want
to escape the realities of the world now
ultimately that's on you to decide but
no matter how repetitive the game got i
constantly thought about how this all
felt intentional in the goal to become
number one and that kept me going the
game is somehow making fun of video game
tropes like the act of senseless
violence without remorse while also
pointing out that life isn't some
fantasy world where everything can
always work out exactly as you want
that's not a good thing you know
seeking meaning in everything
especially killing so now the answer
you've all been waiting for does the
original no more heroes hold up in 2021
to that i say yes yes it does i think it
can be hard to appreciate no more heroes
on a surface level and i can easily see
why someone would be turned off by the
many things i've mentioned so far but i
also think it's important to look at no
more heroes on its level and understand
where it's coming from this feels like a
very personal story from its creator one
that tells the tale of an otaku who gets
to live out his fantasy but also deal
with the harsh realities of living said
fantasy and despite how i feel about the
more repetitive nature of the game it
only took me 10 hours to beat so it's
really not that much of a grind plus i
barely even scratch the surface of what
happens in the plot of no more heroes
it's a wild ride especially as it goes
on and you're in for a treat if you
decide to play it it's also very helpful
that both no more heroes and no more
heroes 2 reported to the nintendo switch
and pc in the lead up to no more heroes
3 so it's easier than ever to play both
games and catch up on the series you
don't need to find a second hand copy of
the original wii version or play the ps3
port which many believe is a lesser
experience although i've never tried it
personally but if you're already looking
forward to no more heroes 3 then
consider subscribing to our channel as
we'll have a video review and maybe more
if you want it watching this video like
you just did and letting us know in the
comments that you want more no more
heroes content would definitely help
also if you like this format of
revisiting the original entry in a
series in the lead up to the latest
release then let me know that as well
this is a new format i'm trying and if
it does well then i'll consider doing
more and lastly if you did make it this
far and you're listening to me right now
thank you so much for watching i really
do appreciate it for all things gaming
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you